you've heard of the universe but have
you heard of the Multiverse
proponents of the Multiverse claim that
there's a vast possibly infinite array
of other universes universe is different
from our own the Multiverse typically
comes up in discussions between theists
and atheists discussions about what's
called the fine-tuning of the cosmos
theists point out that the universe is
finely tuned for intelligent life they
say that the odds of getting a universe
like ours are so staggeringly small we
can't be here by chance
atheists respond by claiming that if
there's actually an infinite array of
universes well it's not so improbable
that at least one of them would be
capable of supporting intelligent life
in fact many of them might be capable of
supporting intelligent life with
infinity on your side so much is
possible
but wait a moment
theists have Infinity on our side so if
atheists think it's reasonable to appeal
to an infinite array of universes to
explain the features of our universe
obviously they shouldn't have any
objection if theists do the exact same
thing
what do I mean here I mean that theists
can offer a Multiverse response to
What's called the problem of evil or the
argument from Evil and that atheists if
they're consistent can't really object
to our Multiverse response
let's see how this works first we'll
make sure everyone understands the
fine-tuning argument then we'll cover
the Multiverse response to the
fine-tuning argument then we'll make
sure everyone understands the problem of
evil and finally we'll present the
Multiverse response to the problem of
evil so fine tuning to get the idea here
think about a fish tank
I was about seven years old and my
friend Todd got a fish tank with a bunch
of fish for Christmas we were using the
fish tank thermometer as a torpedo to
try to hit the fish and Todd broke the
thermometer all his fish died in the
next few days why because the tank had
to be kept at a specific temperature for
the fish to survive the temperature had
to be finely tuned but not nearly as
finely tuned as the universe the
fundamental structure of the universe
has to be finely tuned for intelligent
life the forces and constants of physics
certain physical quantities the ratios
between the masses of atomic particles
and the properties of elements and
compounds have to be just right or we
wouldn't be here
consider some of the forces of nature
without gravity there'd be no planets
stars or galaxies and I wouldn't even be
able to sit in this chair without the
strong nuclear force protons and
neutrons wouldn't hold together in the
nucleus of an atom and hydrogen would be
the only element on the periodic table
without the electromagnetic force
there'd be no chemical interactions
between atoms and the molecules
necessary for Life couldn't form
but the fact that we have the necessary
forces isn't nearly as surprising as the
fine tuning of the numbers that
physicists plug into the laws of nature
these are the constants of physics the
cosmological constant the gravitational
constant the strong force constant the
fine structure constant these numbers
could have had a wide range of values
and yet the values they actually have
fall into the extremely narrow range
that make biological life possible
part of the reason we're alive is that
the Universe turned out just right for
life
should we attribute this to chance did
we just get lucky
well suppose a murderous psychopath
locks you in a room puts a gun to your
head and hands you two dice he says if
you roll double sixes I'll let you live
if you roll anything else you're dead
now roll
so you roll the dice
double sixes man that was lucky
then he tells you to do it again double
sixes again or you're dead you roll them
again
double sixes that was really lucky
but what if it keeps happening he makes
you roll again and again and again and
day after day year after year you keep
rolling the numbers necessary for Life
your life
does there ever come a point where you
say
come on the dice are loaded
if the answer is yes if there are limits
to what can reasonably be described as
luck then we have to believe that
someone had us in mind when the universe
was created because the odds of getting
a life-permitting universe by chance are
a lot worse than rolling double sixes a
bunch of times
as the late astrophysicist sir Fred
Hoyle said a common sense interpretation
of the facts suggests that a super
intellect has monkeyed with physics as
well as chemistry and biology and that
there are no blind forces worth speaking
about in nature
but atheists have a response it's the
Multiverse response if there are a lot
of universes then maybe the odds of
getting a life permitting Universe
aren't so bad think about it if you're
only dealt five cards in a hand of Poker
and it's the only poker hand you're ever
dealt it would be extremely improbable
for you to get a royal flush
but if you're dealt a million hands and
one of them is a royal flush well that's
not improbable at all because the odds
of getting a royal flush when dealt just
five cards are about one in six hundred
and fifty thousand
so while a life-permitting universe may
seem extremely improbable given the odds
of the laws of nature being just right
for Life what happens if there are an
infinite number of universes
if there are an infinite number of
universes each with its own variations
in the laws of nature suddenly it's not
as surprising that we hit the jackpot in
ours
problem solved right not quite there are
all kinds of objections to the
Multiverse response but I'm going to
ignore all of them
let's just grant that it's perfectly
acceptable to appeal to an infinite
array of unobserved undetectable
universes to explain certain features of
our universe the point I want to make in
this video is that if our atheist
friends get to appeal to the Multiverse
to respond to an argument it's only fair
that we also get to appeal to the
Multiverse to respond to an argument
right
that's fair isn't it atheists you don't
want to be Hypocrites do you
thank you for your anticipated
consistency all right now the main
argument against the existence of God is
called the problem of evil or the
argument from evil here evil doesn't
just include what we normally think of
as evil namely moral evil it also
includes all kinds of human and animal
suffering what we call Natural evil
there are many versions of the argument
from Evil the idea generally is that if
an all-powerful all-knowing perfectly
good being exists there shouldn't be so
much suffering in our world God could do
a better job
theists often respond to the argument
from Evil by offering philosophical or
theological reasons for God to allow or
sometimes to produce the bad things we
see around us philosophical reasons for
God to allow suffering are called
theodices examples of popular theodices
are free will theodices God allows us to
do evil things because Free Will is
important and soul building theodices
suffering actually causes us to grow
morally and spiritually and to develop
virtues like courage and compassion
there are dozens of theodices that are
meant to explain various kinds of evil
and suffering then there are theological
explanations which would be things like
human beings have rebelled against God
and at least some of the bad things that
happen in this world are the result of
that Rebellion
atheists answer these philosophical and
Theological reasons for suffering by
saying in effect
are these things really so important to
God that he has to allow this mess we
see around us is Free Will so important
to God that he has to allow human
trafficking is soul building so
important to God that we need hurricanes
is punishing us for Rebellion so
important to God that animals need to
get caught in the crossfire
and then theists would argue that these
things really are that important
but I'm not going to go in that
direction I'm just going to do what
atheists do I'm going to offer the
Multiverse response to the problem of
evil
I'm simply going to say
what if God created a Multiverse
what if God created an infinite array of
universes God certainly has the power to
do that
suppose God created each Universe with
different features perhaps the vast
majority of alternative universes are
the hedonistic paradises that atheists
say God should have made
but in our universe God did things a
little differently he gave people a
great deal of free will he made a place
where lots of things go wrong so that
people can develop virtues like courage
and compassion he punished Rebellion
can you really say that God couldn't do
this in just one of the infinite
universes he created
on what basis can you say that he
couldn't
your feelings
why should your feelings about the
Multiverse response to the problem of
evil bother us any more than our
feelings about the Multiverse response
to Cosmic fine-tuning bother you
or are you going to say that there's
something really really weird about
appealing to an infinite array of
unobservable undetectable alternative
universes to explain away the features
of the one we actually observe
too late to say that now the problem of
evil has been defeated all thanks to the
Multiverse
I don't make the rules atheists I just
enforce them
by the way if you'd like a fuller
introduction to Cosmic fine tuning be
sure to check out William Lane Craig's
excellent animated video on the fine
tuning of the universe
[Music]